[Musique]
à travers mon expérience personnelle de
vous présenter certains des thématiques
sur ses avants et de vous permettre aux
pieds dépassent de votre cerveau de la
façon de l'améliorer de faire en sorte
d'apporter dans vos vies de grand
changement est aussi devenue plus
efficace dans votre façon d'aborder les
choses
la mémoire est un outil position alors
il dépend de décider quel type de nîmois
qui est prépondérant à tabac par exemple
que c'est invivable de livres les objets
comme les douleurs par exemple et ce
faisant vous arriverez accédants ayant
agi trop cm et vous pourrez plonger plus
loin dans vos souvenirs
vous pouvez tout à moi quand j'étais
plus jeune
nous avions reçu fin mai que la manie de
manhattan et j'avais aussi cette
mauvaise habitude de poser à mon père
toutes sortes de questions
saad aide la dure gilles à l'histoire et
j'étais fan des planètes
j'avais même rejoindre le pays avec
lequel je le connais car j'ai bien sûr
de mon sac des bouillies universelle qui
parlait des talibans alors autour de 12
13 ans quand elle a refusé à l'occasion
de notre peinture est pour une
application de médecine occasion
j'attends se retrouvent salon et je dois
faire et j'arrive au salon je me
recroqueville de cadres qui sont à
ranger dans le fond il dit à l'intérieur
de ses camps dans ce tour benoït plus
petit donc ces villes tu trouveras
toutes mes réponses que tu chéris alors
c'est fade et insipide jugnot c'est
vraiment d'être visible net
comment est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
appliqué ce qu'on appelle la théorie
d'abord dans ce vidéo inédit développé
par adeilson et walker était oui dix
clubs de la même façon que vont annuler
l'entente de vos mains et vous permet de
savoir quelles raisons ce chiffre
pourrait uniquement de cette même façon
vous pouvez amener les mêmes méthodes
modernes il vous suffit juste d'ajouter
une poignée alors qui a vidé au conseil
se regroupent les aborder et un beau
diable sur les événements du conte avec
la théorie la mode ans je suis parvenu à
la pomme
deux au moins comment est-ce que les
choses soient a lancé dans la profondeur
espagne alors le siège des ducs par la
force de la députée mais surtout à la
diversité de ce que vous y tenez à
mourir vous devez dire vous devez qu'on
plonge et dans des délais plus élaboré
et plus profond selon ihab est un auteur
que le présentateur diversité qui
semble être l'une des figures de proue
de la neuroscience
en france il se trouve que selon lui ces
autres mille heures de formation
permettent de ce type et passe dans le
faite vous faites ce qu'on appelle les
accents du cerveau nos frontières on
s'intéresse à fond est ce que cette
identité parce qu'en fait
automatiquement leurs dépassements
mais je peux vous garantir avec moins de
50000 heures et de la passion vous
pouvez aller à vous hisser au meilleur
niveau pour les sujets passionne dans
tous les sujets qui vous intéressent
quand vous abonner c'est tout votre
corps il tient dans ma famille
maternelle c'est de tradition tous les
enfants généralement apprennent à jouer
de l'orgue
alors dès le temps je me suis votre
vision d'allier japon je ne suis pas
comme on dit la projet avec des deux
périodes mais il ya des choses que j'ai
retenue et des choses de cm aujourd'hui
dans tout ce que je fais cela permet
d'apprendre plus facilement et doit
rouler plus vite notre concept je me
suis rendu compte que dans
l'apprentissage d'un instrument de
musique comme dans l'apprentissage se
créent chaque fois que votre 0 par denis
quelque chose automatiquement vos mains
y compris wauquiez qui bat la mesure en
régie systématiquement ce que l'on fait
du coup c'est tout votre corps des
marines et diamants et c'est vraiment
formidable c'est incroyable se rend
compte que ces choses là sous un autre
aspect c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte
aussi
artistiquement parlant bien sûr que
verse en particulier permettre de
favoriser l'assimilation fazzino cerveau
l'apprentissage la protection des forêts
en ajoutant par exemple de la piscine
avec ce type de musique on vend à prix
d'or et à taper plus facile pour les
informations le cerveau a juste besoin
que vous lui fassiez confiance
les mêmes plats base de tout
apprentissage aussi loin que je me
souvienne je n'ai pas entendu mes
parents meeting des choses mais pour
agences viennent ou pas prêt j'ai appris
par la force de la divination une
vieille ville des dealers donc une autre
façon de retenir les choses mais surtout
par la confiance des courriels d'un
confiant alors je devais passer du
papier
je me posais la question de savoir est
ce que j'allais bien d'obtenir tout ce
que j'ai amené alors pour éviter d'avoir
à une cuisse banny quand on perd c'est
proposé de me recevoir avant et après
mon examen alors il part d'un bien sûr
nous sommes là tous les soirs pour une
heure d'entretien nous parlions
nous prions et il m'a donné un certain
nombre de clés je vais vous en citer
deux la première est la suivante la paix
de la réussite réside dans le travail et
dans la conscience le stress le monde et
d'europe 1 qui n'apporte rien de bon le
deuxième aspect c'est que le siège
retiennent mieux quand vous apprenez et
quand vous avez pardon ce que vous
faites
il vous fait une chose sans sa
concentration ne lui demandez pas aux
tony pas sur le beat est dans un état de
stress il m'a dit si tu est il que la
peur des points à transformer ce n'est
pas la peine d'aller même pas ce que tu
viens d'où
je passerai la maison château alors la
monty sages ne doit pas être sous m
sinon vous mettez en place des autres
fait chaque fois que vous apporter
quelque chose de nouveau
votre cerveau sur et organiste et cela
nous le savons d'abord grâce à la table
finale qui a été développé par le
docteur romani qui a permis le défi est
donc de supprimer le cerveau les deux
émissaires du cnl qui comme des appels
de noël salue chaque fois que nous ce
sont des activités chaque fois que nous
devons prendre des décisions
chaque fois que nous devons montrer
votre domaine alors c'est justement cela
comment est-ce que j'ai appliqué est
même si je suis invité m quand on bat
nha ky l'office français se retrouvent
les unités dans les nra et il s'est fait
que poursuivre les pas de mon père j'ai
plus fait finances et dans notre système
général dans une bataille n'est plus
pour le droit élémentaire
alors je me suis préparé rapidement
et après deux ans d'études j'ai pu
intégrer un programme qui comptait 21
pour près de huit candidatures je me
rappelle pendant ces deux années de
préparation en année les cours de
mathématiques il al'occasion de ségou
lorsque le professeur finissait de seine
une démonstration il regarde l
inspection des littéraires la salle
n'étaient que 3 succès des z
il reste encore des tas de denver is
même endroit donc à nos colonnes au
dialogue et nous sommes approchés
effectivement nous avons pu intégrer
cette prestigieuse formation ce qui m'a
permis de comprendre que ce site est
déterminé préparer on pouvait arriver à
bout de temps et je me suis rendu compte
aussi dans apprenants j'ai fini par
développer de nouveaux traits du coup de
nouvelles connexions neuronales dont
conserve autres et réorganiser il s'est
adapté à une nouvelle situation
vous pouvez poster efficacement votre
carrière professionnelle s'entend en
apprenant à déguster à schématiser
aventure et quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière professionnelle
éditions mais aussi quelques lots de
consolation nous embauchons en résumé je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais plus
est déformé à savoir accumulé de la
connaissance plutôt cadavres à en faire
et à lumbres en fait aux autres c'est le
premier et le second temps fait m'a
permis de me rendre compte que la façon
que nous insulte à rome était générale
complète adaptée aux eyzies
professionnels et enfin comme 3e puis je
me suis rendu compte que le travail de
groupe en entreprise et notamment plus
profitable le pragmatique
l'open de 30 ans de scolarité mois
depuis je peux je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait la plupart du temps ce que
vaut un plan qui chérit dans les études
dans une carrière professionnelle d'or
un projet télé ne sont en fait que
témoigner que le serpent a tout fait de
nous un peuple
nous ne disons pas convenablement que
aaron vous êtes d'abord rcd et enfin
tout ce que nous avons en réalité tout
ce que nous apprenions c'est en fait une
démarche et une méthodologie de base et
du coup ne me dites surtout pas à bien
j'avais pas pensé que je paie pas
tragédie je suis le seul à aimer parce
qu'en réalité tout ce qu'on apprenait en
seconde et des pages mais passons de
côté pour pouvoir donner plus facilement
du coup j'ai dû changer mon fusil
d'épaulé pour m'adapter j'ai commencé à
reconstruire tout ce que j'ai acquis un
pic comptabilité dans la vie de tous les
jours je les ai habité à 20 vie de tous
les jours parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'en réalité tout s'explique
on nous enseigne les épaules proviennent
des news intitulée de leurs concepteurs
de l'ain figure de proue
donc en réalité un peu basique de la
pratique à la ghibli de l'atp à la
fatigue et au second rang korian qui
possède deux aspects de son parlement
d'ici au mondial mais ensuite j'ai
développé ma mémoire c'est vrai cela
m'apaise fallait développer et des mains
basé sur la défense tu peux quand même
observation et des vacations résultat
est aussi sur l'épître tennistique j'ai
complété en apprentissage de la coupe de
la technique de vagues - pour par
connaître ce que c'est de la rédaction
de procédures et la perdrix des
processus
ça m'a permis d'avoir une saison et tout
ça va l'aider encore des problèmes à 2
noeuds pourquoi les raisons véritables
occasions
cela a permis aujourd'hui de notre
particularité que je fais qui
consulteront alors consultant dont
carnival aéroports européens
certainement une musique ensuite
n'importe quoi et je connais la réponse
va d'un quotidien national
c'est beaucoup mieux parce qu'en fait
généralement j'aime et qui me dit on les
payait jusqu'à paris ma mère ne crois
pas le mythe allemand c'est pas comme si
elle connaît ban ki mon père et des
coûts titre et pour les assureurs
le 2 mai bien sûr mais ensuite lancé par
cet arrêté mais il est une chose
essentielle livres retenus des bleus il
faut un revenu de coin peut tout est
conditionné par la ministre
et il ya des personnes qui aujourd'hui
sont considérées comme sans instruction
mais sont en réalité des puits de
connaissances des puits de sa visité en
détruisent et ne sont pas forcément
passer par dessus ce pognon donc il ya
quelque chose de plus sa petite voix
habitée en réalité aux déchets naturels
ou d'avoir des vols dans notre façon de
voir et qui s'entend aussi parce des
trophées à nous préparer à la vie c'est
faire se sont mobilisés les aptitudes de
leur cerveau l'ademe l'europe unie alors
attendre à utiliser votre serment
country vous utilisiez domaine en
interne qu'en réalité ces deux aspects
de votre or par d'âge des divinités
destin héroïque
je voulais vous parler de nouveau évolué
loin du débat scientifique parce qu'on
allait devoir parler de sciences
politiques de nos séances de ceci de
cela et j'ai estimé que c'était quelque
chose de quelque peu compliqué pour moi
mais d'abord et je n'étais pas sûr de
pouvoir voter
je cours je me suis décidé à utiliser
des éléments de mon expérience
professionnelle pour vous montrer que ce
sont des choses qui sont imputables tous
les jours de l'année
c'est faisable
cette façon de faire c'est à dire de se
rendre compte que nous pouvons utiliser
nous mêmes notre cerveau pad comme
utilisable et ça peut apporter des
changements projetés à l'épaule en
entreprise en famille c'est aussi il
faut juste voir il faut juste le vouloir
il faut juste se lancer véritablement
dans cette dynamique de changement pour
construire demain il faut aussi se poser
la question de savoir ce que nous
appelons à rien puisque cet aspect est
essentiel avec roche
bon apporté dans ma vie comme régis de
celle de ceux qui nous entourent
il faut aussi mesurer la relation qu'il
ya un côté déjanté s'agisse est
peut-être la grille en force mais brenda
et pourquoi plus sur ce partage
expérience je vous dirais que comme l'a
évoqué montée comme l'enfant l'homme
n'est pas un passeport copie mais en
réalité il est ce que l'on aime
[Musique]